when i studied antisocial behavior and  particularly at mcgill i studied female  and male antisocial behavior male  antisocial behavior tends to be much  more physically violent and so most of  the people who are imprisoned are male  mostly because we imprison violent  offenders  which is kind of interesting we don't  necessarily imprison  white-collar criminals even if they  defraud like 60 000 people but you know  a mugger well we're going to lock them  up and yeah i can understand that  although not entirely defrauding 60 000  people out of their pension isn't  exactly nothing either but in any case  it's almost all men in prison and it's  almost all violent offenders what's the  female equivalent of anti-social  personality and it's much more subtle  but a lot of it is  reputation destruction and exclusion  mean girl syndrome